dr sloan and the cube queen have finally
been defeated and the entire world as we
know it has been turned on its head it's
a new chapter in fortnite a new story to
uncover and it's all built around the
seven to understand what will happen in
this season and beyond we first need to
travel back in time to chapter two
[Music]
the invasion and cube storylines brought
together two powerful teams to do battle
the imagined order the guys who up to
this point have had full control over
the zero point and the reality we call
zero and their opponents the last
reality a misfit band of aliens and cube
devotees led by the cube queen herself
over both seasons io led by the
incredibly intelligent and frighteningly
manipulative dr sloan found a way to
place a team of operatives on the
mothership before blowing that thing out
of the sky this caused debris to hit the
island including cubes and more cubes
this then revealed the cube queen who
brought together the convergence and
attempted to take control or destroy the
island whichever came first the loopers
set up for the final battle and were
assisted by a rogue last reality cube
glowing blue he helped stave off the
attack but it was all in vain the last
reality were far too strong and io and
the loopers were defeated of course
that's not how this story ends as the
seven led by the foundation came back to
the island to make this battle a
three-way fight three factions going
head to head to head for supremacy above
ground and below
in the i o facility beneath us we see
agent jones shackled and interrogated by
dr sloan herself when the foundation
arrives to break him free to truly
understand why a member of the seven
would free an io agent requires a little
more backtracking to the primal season
this was the moment in time jones
resigned from io and created a pact with
the foundation to save reality from the
clutches of the imagined order johnsy
was thought to be lost on the island
becoming another looper but it's now
confirmed he was picked up by io who
have been extracting information from
him for weeks or maybe months
[Music]
the two members of the seven above
ground scientist and visitor were
outnumbered by the last reality and
reverted back to their original plan it
turns out what happened next was not the
end of their plan the visitor who hasn't
said a word flew off back into space
while the scientist and a bunch of us
loopers began an escape attempt on foot
jumping down into the isle facility
towards the zero point we met up with
jones and the foundation and were told
we had reached safety but the last
reality did not relent a caretaker dove
deep underwater and broke the glass
flooding the bridge reaching the surface
we watched as the cube queen was
submerged ending the attack by the last
reality at least for a while a new
island was discovered a new world to
explore and a new chapter began and the
foundation finally gave us an
explanation about the entire storyline
we've been living through
i suppose i owe you an explanation
we've all been through a lot the last
few years and there's much more you
don't even remember
we've all fought a good fight
and until we set the 0.3 we'll be facing
threats like the last reality
and worse
there will be no escaping it
that's why i need your help to destroy
the imagined order
as long as they're exploiting the zero
point
everything is in danger
with your help we can free ourselves
from this place and leave for good
we can all go home
oh so flat earthers may be onto
something reality zero is a single
island all alone in the depths of space
the foundation gave us three key points
about the chapter moving forward one the
last reality is not the only threat
coming for the zero point we should
expect other factions to try and claim
its power maybe this will be how midas
and his shadows come back into the story
this chapter and we should never count
out io and doctor sloane two our purpose
is to destroy the imagined order to free
the zero point and three once we've done
all this we can leave the loop and go
back home wherever home may be before we
can stop io our task looks to be
bringing the seven back together they
are more fractured than we first thought
from what we've heard some of them are
missing completely and others just
aren't friends anymore before we look
into that let's check up on the ones we
know about on the new island over at the
sanctuary protected by the foundation
are seven rock columns thanks to the
file names we are almost totally
convinced each of these stone pillars
corresponds to a member of the seven the
foundation the visitor the scientist the
paradigm and the newly depicted
characters the sisters and the origin
somehow we need to reunite them all
we've seen four of them so far the
visitor the scientist and the foundation
all work together to flip the island yet
the paradigm was not part of this
mission and she is still to be seen
officially already this chapter the
scientist has given us an insight into
the paradigm's influence on the future
story through a secure broadcast the
scientists audio logs tell us well
listen for yourself
paradigm
uh it's me i'm i'm guessing you heard
what happened look i know our history is
complicated
but i want you to know
i never lost faith in you okay i did but
only for five minutes maybe maybe a few
weeks tops uh
it's hard to believe that someone
who went through what you went through
would hold the line but i i know you
did so we really do not deserve your
help right now not at all but
we need it
from these early season comms we know
that flipping the island is only one
step towards freeing the zero point but
more importantly we now know that
members of the seven do not trust the
paradigm something has happened before
we joined this story which fractured the
entire relationship of the group and in
particular the foundation and the
paradigm these two don't get along so
i'm expecting a punch up when she
finally joined the story i know that
among our ranks there are still some
mixed feelings about the paradigm but
for the sake of survival we need to
think of her as an ally we are the seven
we have a duty to rise above grudges and
petty disagreements for the greater good
and yes foundation i'm looking at you i
can see your face through that mask
regardless of the past
there is no future without her the
paradigm has once again pinged the seven
suggesting she is closer than they know
and as the season goes on we will learn
more about her and her importance to the
storyline can i add my theory now if you
know me you'll know i've always believed
paradigm is singularity they are one and
the same person here's what i think
happened paradigm created an alter ego
singularity to get close to the zero
point acting like a double agent inside
the imagined order this is evidenced by
her helmet being left on the desk the
last time we saw a stable zero point to
defend that zero point from attack
singularity created a mech this would
mean she saved us but she also is
responsible for weakening the zero point
claiming some of its power to get
through that battle causing cracks and
ultimately destabilizing reality this
would explain why the seven lost all
faith in paradigm and will struggle to
trust her again if this is true paradigm
will have some explaining to do and i
don't think foundation will settle for a
conversation he'll want to fight but
don't trust this this is just a theory a
fortnight theory which means absolutely
nothing yet
back to those pillars again though the
members of the team we don't yet know
about are the sisters two rocks can be
found side by side suggesting the
sisters are exactly that extremely close
members of the team we have heard about
them once before from the foundation the
moment he and agent jones made a pact to
work together it was due to two name
drops geno and the sisters
[Music]
i can get you to jenna
and the sisters i can get you all of
them so the sisters are confirmed to be
members of the seven and that seems to
be the only reason foundation saved
agent jones in the last live event and
the final member of the seven is the
origin we know absolutely nothing about
this member yet judging by their name
they were there at the beginning when
the zero point was created the origin of
it all i can't wait to find out who that
is i wonder how many people think the
last member of the seven will actually
be the mustard we call donald how meta
would that be
the loopers on the island all remain
trapped and destined to repeat the same
22 minutes until the end of time yet
some members have escaped the loop and
live outside of it but still on the
island look around and you'll find the
joneses former snapshots forced to fight
in an endless war over the zero point
and already the scientist has asked us
to check if they can be trusted it seems
that alliances on this new island are
fraught and uncertain just like the
relationship of many members of the
seven but wait we do know the name of
the big bad guy coming to the future of
fortnite for many seasons now we've
known geno is important to the
foundation he sacrificed himself to
protect the zero point thanks to that
one word from agent jones and since then
geno is confirmed to be in control of
the zero point and as we have always
been told io control the zero point
we've all jumped to the conclusion that
geno is a high ranking member of the
imagined order and io aren't out of this
story they are just stuck on the other
side of the island for now whether geno
and io attack us first or the seven
become proactive and take the battle to
the imagined order it's surely all
coming during chapter three but one step
at the time my friends we first need to
reunite the seven and will we finally
have proof that the paradigm and
singularity are one and the same person
chapter three is gonna be one hell of a
time i'm adam you're awesome i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you